太鼓月初め社長です今日はちょっとうれしくトップ代わりの話をしようと思っており
ます
こんな感じになっておりますこれさっき母ちゃんからもらった手紙っていうかメモなん
ですよね
年上の人には後輩であっても敬語を使ってください上から目線はような感じです
今日1はじめしゃちょー坊ちゃんツアー1日の
28時間ちょいくらいいつもパソコンで方のかしてます動画編集だけじゃなくてご飯に
人が見たよねこれがいろいろ調べ戻してね2ロンドか書いたりいろんなことをパソコン
でやるわけなんですけどもあの
すごいポスト部体が痛いんですよ本当にそれはねちょっとあの実際いっぱいですやその
一室でこの椅子なんですけども高誘電は普通にしっかりしたいい子なんですけどもう
全然ねあの1時間と重なるのは全然いい数字つあるの全然いいんですけどもいいじゃね
28時間あるとなると痛いんですよお尻がね大正解たくてそのまま道具怪我しちゃっ
きーがで行った
怪我じゃないんですけども怪我したとか身体の負担がで返っ保有したというだから僕は
で掘った長時間触れる人がほっそりいらっしゃったんですよ長時間されるでしょうね
色々調べた犬が
ゲームじゃあというのがオススメみたいですでこのゲーミング遅延はなぜかと言います
とゲームをするよねっていうのかなパソコンチェア一つを変えるだけで作業のスピード
座っているときの心地よさは全然違ってきますつまり加速をいっぱい咲かせんとっては
伊勢がものを言うよもう長い地下水剃ってるわけですか他子安5でローゼってきたん
ですよ
いつも感心がない完璧な生活を送れるというわけで全部教
いいいい
頭を買ってみましたそが見たければ所アイデア早速皆様ハ穴と履けるなぁ相手に1回
なんか来ないよ
米国で刀こちらでございますなんていうかわかりません何だろうか鯖が dxr bk
n ですよ
これがほんと日本じゃ売っちっぷりちゃうかー寺キャロン下戸ノイズを使えば作業が
一緒
外面できるチャンスだってゲームができる共著靴はれるっていうねもうパソコン遠慮靴
買う人にとった本当に奇跡の逸品です例えば人生の左官寝るよねそういう買い物する
気分です浅漬け台風抜きにいきましょう
普通ドゥンたら僕はもうゼロスからおっしゃあ一揆とでーっきますもうでーっに結構
パーありますこんな感じですかぁ今日ねえねえだろすぐ作っ
ちょっと本気で作ってみま組み立てがないそんなに何かたくさんないんですちょっと
順番でとりあえずはまず
座面と背もたれの固定
それかちゃまからねぇ
ここから何をするかですよもうボルトプレックスのあー
を招いちゃうわかったブーケなんて待って来だろうもう何点ねあお前でいるところは
ここだろう
あああああん
ne
はぁううううううっうぅうう
me
これは颯爽なる男性ラッシャー恋
これ待ってきたんじゃねぇこれしてからこうだってますね
まあ固定プレワークワンちゃん見たら教えません
さあこうすることによって後にこういうフットレストができますまたもう一つだ
多いができたできた一は全全
完成しました
あっはぁんっ
あっあった
悪いっ
何カッ
このネバー欲しかったんではこう頑張ってガッツとというかじゃねあっあってきた
もっとスムーズじゃないのか
ああそうそうそうそれが欲しかったそう f ブースやっぱしても誰が動かせるのが
でかいんですよねやっぱねこれもうちょい待ってすっごい剃り心地がいいんですけど
空いてるでしゃべりにちょっとネタじゃないほうのハイフォンとしましたこれで根暗
だったら刑務としたり寝パソコン
編集とかねデスクワークとするんですよやっぱりねこれは聴力が打つと今まで使って
ネットの企画でかなり
一緒の時ですね
行くよ僕はまああんまりねーなんかするとカーペットが家具とかにあんまり興味なくて
ちょっと久しぶりにまともなさんと役に立つ買い物なってきました
だから使うかしているわけではないんですけどフィットするんですよねやっぱりこう
いう背もたれがこういう部分が痛くなりそうなところをしっかり捉えて本当にいいいい
ですこういう日ちょっと高いんですけどもう買ってそんじゃない
と思いますあとずっと使えると思うんではたら参考にしてみてください
じゃん
うは久しぶりに良い道だ
def